[Musique]
un détour par cette boutique du centre
ville de beaune suffit pour s'en rendre
compte
la tradition a du bon surtout sur les
étiquettes fond beige ou crème blason
dorure à première vue elles se
ressemblent toutes beaucoup et pourtant
vincent clément le gérant la sur les
lignes sont en train de bouger doucement
on a quand même une tendance à aller de
plus en plus vers de lait pur mais là
encore sur le nuits saint georges on
retrouve le blason tic est un peu moins
chargée pour le coup graphiquement mais
il ya quand même les signes distinctifs
sur les 3659 domaine viticole que compte
la bourgogne rares sont ceux qui osent
vraiment s'éloigner des codes dans les
choses des plus audacieuses qu'on a
découvert ces derniers temps vous avez
le le domaine des rouges que voilà qu'à
se fait toute une série d'étiquettes qui
sont assez assez chouette avec où on
évoque la nature donc le thème des
oiseaux
ils en ont plusieurs en l'occurrence
c'est intéressant de voir à chaque fois
donc en fait il ya un graphisme
différents par appellation qui est
décliné mais avec on reconnaît quand
même bien le fait que ce soit le même
domaine qui signe ses bouteilles
les étiquettes de vin c'est la
spécialité de l'imprimerie roi chagny
pense que la dorure chocolat ça apporte
vraiment que cette signature
carette c'est sympa shirwa on cette
année nous avons enfin en 2018 nous
avons réalisé un chiffre d'affaires de
près de 11 millions d'euros qui
correspond à peu près à près d'un
milliard des tic est produite
c'est une étiquette qui vient se
positionner soit devant soit derrière ce
qu'on appelle la contre étiquette ou
alors un médaillon ou une collerette
quand il s'agit de champagne ici la
moitié des clients et bourguignonnes et
la concurrence rude 80 imprimerie
spécialisée en france et une dizaine
dans la région pour se distinguer roi
devait se donner les moyens d'innover 14
millions d'euros investis sur le site
depuis 2000 14,5 ligne d'impression
bientôt 6 et une différence qui se fait
clairement aujourd'hui sur la matière
des étiquettes du bois pour se bat et
élevé en fûts de chêne du papier toucher
peau de pêche et même du velours le
challenge principal de notre métier
c'est de faire évoluer l'étiquette de
vincent casser le code bourguignon et
donc ça y va par petites touches
on peut pas partir sur des maquettes des
maquettes comme on voit par exemple sur
d'autres régions où on a des choses qui
sont vérité avec des couleurs des
dorures des choses beaucoup plus flashy
il faut rester dans un code très
classique classique
chic et demain éco-responsable comme la
dernière innovation maison en papier
recyclé avec des encres à base de
pigments naturels charbon de bois de
ceps de vigne et au chrs l'art de
l'étiquette colle à l'air du temps
[Musique]